[Music]
foreign
every two minutes a child is born with
sickle cell disease most of these
children especially if they live in low
and middle income countries will die
within the first few years of life often
before the diagnosis is known sickle
cell disease impacts millions of people
around the world yet it is rarely
prioritized in global health research
advocacy or funding sickle cell disease
is a genetic blood disorder that affects
hemoglobin the protein inside red blood
cells that carries oxygen to tissues
throughout the body in a healthy person
red blood cells are round and flexible
allowing for smooth travel through small
blood vessels and effective
transportation of oxygen to where it is
needed in a person with sickle cell
disease however many red blood cells are
Crescent shaped like the farm tool known
as a sickle these sickled red blood
cells are hard sticky and inflexible
they are unable to travel through the
bloodstream efficiently often getting
stuck and slowing or blocking the
delivery of oxygen compared to a healthy
red blood cell which has a lifespan of
120 days sickled cells only live for 10
to 20 days resulting in anemia a
shortage of red blood cells in the body
one of the most common and debilitating
symptoms of sickle cell disease is
sudden intense episodes of pain caused
by the lack of oxygen this significantly
impairs the daily life of sickle cell
patients since they may need frequent
hospital visits for pain management
sickle cell disease can and does affect
all parts of the body
stroke increased risk of infection and
chronic damage the heart kidneys and
lungs are just some complications from
the disease sickle cell disease is
caused by a single genetic mutation that
affects hemoglobin genes are sections of
DNA that provide instructions for
individual characteristics and we
inherit one copy of DNA from each parent
for recessive conditions like sickle
cell disease two abnormal copies of the
gene are needed to pass down the disease
person with only one copy of the
abnormal Gene has the sickle cell trait
and is a carrier of the disease although
they have no symptoms they run the risk
of passing down the gene to their
children when each parent carries one
copy of the abnormal Gene there is a one
in four chance that their child will
have sickle cell disease why does this
mutated Gene continue to persist in the
gene pool if it has such dangerous
effects the Sickle Cell mutations spread
Generations ago as a protective
adaptation against malaria individuals
with sickle cell trait have slight
differences in the red blood cells that
prevent severe malaria and provides a
survival Advantage malaria is common
near the equator and for this reason
many people with a sickle cell trait
have genetic Origins from this region of
the world sickle cell disease affects
India and sub-Saharan Africa the most in
these areas as much as 25 percent of the
population can pass down the disease
there are simple and effective ways to
prevent sickle cell disease and treat
most of its complications because
symptoms can begin as early as the first
year of life and are often fatal the
first step is diagnosing sickle cell
disease early while newborn screening is
common in high income areas it is not
available to low-income regions such as
sub-Saharan Africa and India as a result
many children die from complications
that are unknowingly caused by sickle
cell disease and thus not accounted for
in global health statistics
starting medication immediately can
reduce nearly all the symptoms
associated with the disease and increase
life expectancy
hydroxyurea is an inexpensive and
effective medication for sickle cell
disease that increases the quantity of
fetal hemoglobin as a result red blood
cells are bigger rounder and less likely
to form into the sickle shape despite
these Solutions newborn screening in
hydroxyurea are not available for most
people born with sickle cell disease
because sickle cell disease is not
considered a global Health priority
programs around the world have focused
more on preventing and treating other
conditions such as HIV and tuberculosis
leaving sickle cell disease invisible
within the global Health landscape in
the field of science however sickle cell
disease has increased invisibility with
the rise of new scientific advancements
a group of Technologies collectively
known as gene therapy can directly fix
the genetic mutation that causes sickle
cell disease crispr cast 9 Gene editing
is just one example but its use is still
undergoing clinical trials while these
possibilities are exciting basic
solutions to the disease must be
accessible throughout the world
sickle cell disease first needs to be
recognized and prioritized as an
important Global health problem with
collaboration from governments health
organizations industry and Academia by
doing so every person with sickle cell
disease can have the potential to live
healthy lives regardless of where they
are born
[Music]
thank you